members and Friends of the West Point
community in particular
Colonel Karen Colonel Zupan colleagues
in the trenches who teach philosophy
2:01 and the nearly 500 cadets now
taking this course good evening to all
and welcome
I'm Robert Tully professor of philosophy
at the academy our guest speaker tonight
a man of extraordinary accomplishment is
Noam Chomsky Institute professor of
linguistics and philosophy at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
his reputation precedes him here by
leaps and bounds just six months ago the
British Journal of current affairs
Prospekt conducted a poll among its more
than 20,000 readers to identify today's
leading global public intellectual in
the list of a hundred such figures
professor Chomsky came first drawing
more than twice the votes received by
the runner-up Umberto Eco in the eyes of
this journal professor Chomsky belongs
to the as they said the age of the great
oppositional thinker opposition has
indeed been a consistent feature of
Professor Chomsky's public life since
the 1960's he has been a determined and
acerbic critic of American foreign
policy he has denounced politicians of
both parties for hubris and blindness
and condemned American Society for
tolerating the grip of big business on
politics and the pervasive influence of
mass media if he has been given more to
condemnation than to praise that may
well be the world's fault not his
professor Chomsky has launched his
attacks in newspapers journals and
magazines on radio and television and in
public forums pronouncing on the major
issues of the day from Vietnam to
Central America the Middle East the war
on terror and of course Iraq his
articles and essays on political topics
alone number more than 200 that at least
is where I gave up counting in addition
there are hers more than 50 books on
political matters beginning in 1969 with
a
American power and the new mandarins and
continuing to the present with the
recently published failed States however
this amazing productivity constitutes
only half the picture seem seemingly to
people fill the shoes of one Noam
Chomsky his protest and denunciations
will eventually recede from public view
but posterity will certainly always
remember Noam Chomsky as the single
thinker the non global non public
intellectual who once revolutionized the
science of linguistics Chomsky's work in
linguistic burst upon the scene in the
late 1950s and was steadily consolidated
in a vast number of articles and more
than 30 books he gave linguistics a new
starting point Chomsky set out to answer
a fundamental question what makes
possible the endowment of human language
itself what lies beneath the enormous
variety of spoken languages he theorized
that our familiar languages derived from
an underlying Universal grammar a set of
operational rules in which native
children already possess sufficient
skill to enable them unthinkingly to
become speakers of their parents
language in just a few years whether
this underlying grammar is a function of
the mind or of the brain was of
secondary concern to Chomsky as a
linguistic aim to codify and give formal
shape to the rules by which the language
learner naturally operates this is
science in an abstract but profound
sense the new direction that Chomsky
gave to linguistics made his project
comparable to the work done by Whitehead
and Russell a half-century earlier who
aspired to base both formal logic and
number theory on a set of first
principles his achievement on behalf of
linguistics was also in the spirit of
two great European rationalists the
philosophers Descartes and Kant who had
sought in their own ways and for
different purposes
to find anchorage for our experience of
the world in the workings of an
objective human reason to selves then
the public controversy list and the
academic scientist to voices but one
noam chomsky to such divergent interests
have a foundation is there an underlying
unity to the voices I think the answer
can be found in the same European
tradition from which also comes the view
that the moral will is the essential
component of human reason according to
the rationalist we recognize the
rightness or wrongness of human actions
just as we Intuit the necessary truth of
some propositions our ethical judgments
express the workings of the moral law
and a sharpened insight compels us to
take an ethical stand if we have the
courage the rationalist with courage
reject self-deception and the dominance
of feeling the chief concern is with
what it is right to do not with weather
consequences make the action right above
all the rationalist upholds a universal
perspective that treats people as ends
rather than as means actions contrary to
this perspective deserve to be exposed
and criticized all the more so if they
are the actions of governments that
abuse their nearly absolute power for
the sake of self-interest Noam Chomsky
is a passionate rationalist yet his
endeavor has not been to advance a novel
theory of ethics the moral certainties
that compel him to speak are not
theoretical they are the stuff of
everyday moral intuitions simple and
easily recognized but in need of a voice
how these certainties are applied is the
stuff of controversy but the dust of
political and social debate all too
easily obscures the strong moral
convictions that underlie them I do not
apologize for these lengthy remarks
about professor Chomsky it cannot be
said that a person of such remarkable
complexity needs no introduction to use
a waren phrase he has come to speak to
us tonight about some aspects of Just
War theory after which he will want to
engage the students the cadets of
philosophy 2:01 in discussion and
priority in the question and answer
period will be given to the cadets let
this discussion be what all
philosophical debate
aims to be objective open respectful
fair well argued in one word rational
please join me now in welcoming our
guest professor Noam Chomsky
Thanks
I think a useful place to start might be
with a recent academic study by an
Oxford professor of traditions of war
which contrasts two leading paradigms in
the study of Just War what the author
calls the brodien and Republican
interpretations first pair a paradigm
traces back to hugo grotius famed 17th
century humanists who found that the
dominant framework of thinking on laws
of war within this paradigm law war is
an act of States and just war proposals
are means to humanize to introduce
humanity in warfare it's one tradition
the contrasting Republican paradigm
traces back to Rousseau and the uprising
against monarchy in feudalism and the
late 18th century including the American
Revolution this paradigm blends war with
justice with liberty equality individual
and community rights whatever else may
fall within our concept of justice
well these positions are of course
idealization x' the real world is more
complex
the formal implementation of efforts to
introduce humanity into warfare do not
simply disregard the questions of
justice but they do put them to the
margins they're not central to the
codification of the principles of World
Order and practice with single exception
of the Universal Declaration of Human
Rights which has a pretty tattered
history well despite real-world
complexities the differences between
these two approaches
- just war I think deserve attention in
considering both the issues that are
addressed and those that are ignored we
might ask whether that itself is just
there are at least three major sources
of insight into the concepts of Just War
the first is the scholarly literature
the second is the underlying notions of
human nature that underlie our moral
judgments and the third is the
International codifications so I'd like
to say a few words about each of these
topics I think it may help to indicate
in advance where I'm heading in brief my
own conclusions are that the literature
merits careful attention but is
ultimately not very instructive about
just war secondly that the notions of
human nature should be at the heart of
the discussion
although serious inquiry into this is
still in its early stages and third that
the codifications
are seem to be sensible but actions in
the real world
all too often reinforce famous maxim of
Tacitus that the strong do as they can
while the weak do as they must so let's
start with some remarks on some of the
current literature on just war one of
the most recent studies is Michael
Walters book arguing about war which
merits particular attention not only
because of the high praise it's received
but also because Walter is responsible
for the largely responsible for the
recent revival of Just War Theory the
strengths I think the book reveals both
the strengths and the weaknesses of Just
War Theory the strengths are that many
of the conclusions seem plausible enough
at least to me but
particularly those conclusions that
pretty much reiterate standard
codifications the weakness is that
despite the book's title arguing about
war it's very hard to find an argument
you might try that as an experiment and
more accurately while arguments are
sometimes detectable they rely
personally on such premises as seems to
me entirely justified or I believe or no
doubt and there's almost no effort to
bring in relevant background information
and evidence
Walter gives to paradigm examples which
in which case he simply asserts that the
wars are just in fact so obviously just
that argument is unnecessary the two
examples are Afghanistan and Kosovo
he describes the invasion of Afghanistan
as a triumph of Just War theory which
stands alongside the bombing of Serbia
in 1999 as a nun controversial case of
just war no argument is felt to be
necessary although in either case it
doesn't take much effort to think of
possible evidence that might bear on the
pronouncement that these are triumphs of
Just War theory and these are
considerations that would certainly be
brought by brought up by just were
theorists if the responsibility for the
military action lay elsewhere well for
lack of time I'll skip illustrations but
can come back to them if you'd like to
be clear I'm not asking whether the
bombings of Afghanistan and Serbia were
right or wrong maybe they were maybe
they weren't I'm asking a different
question namely what does Just War
Theory have to say about it and I think
if you look closely you'll find that the
answer is that it has nothing to say
about it
we're left with assertions of the
authors that state violence was
justified on
virtually so and any consequences
whether anticipated or not are entirely
no doubt the fault of the official enemy
well another reason and also highly
regarded inquiry into Just War theory is
by moral political philosopher Jean Elka
Elstein the paradigm of Just War she
writes is the bombing of Afghanistan and
she adds that nearly everyone with the
exception of absolute pacifists and a
few lunatics agree that the bombing of
Afghanistan was clearly a just war
argument ended in reality nearly
everyone excludes substantial categories
of people of the majority of the world's
population for example even in Europe
far more so in Latin America and also
leading Afghans who had been fighting
the Taliban and including u.s. favorites
and virtually all eight agencies working
there but what's relevant is that this
constitutes the sole argument to
establish that the war was just in fact
uncontroversially so the facts are
irrelevant and though further argument
is needed well Elston does provide
criteria for just war so we at least
have the rudiments of a theory four
criteria I'll read them first criterion
the war must be openly declared or
otherwise what otherwise authorized by a
legitimate Authority second it must
begin with the right intentions third
forces justified if it protects the
innocent from certain harm as when a
country has certain knowledge that
genocide will commence on a certain date
fourth it must be a last resort
after other possibilities for the
redress and defense of the values at
stake have been explored well
the first two conditions are vacuous
declaration of war by an aggressor
confers no support whatsoever for a
claim of Just War and even the worst
criminals claim right intentions the
third and fourth conditions sound
unreasonable but they have no relevance
at all clearly to the case of
Afghanistan
so therefore else teens perish paradigm
example collapses entirely under her own
criteria he had just one word on the
classic modern work Michael Walters just
and unjust wars which I believe you've
been reading my personal judgement is
that his conclusions are generally very
reasonable also pretty much in accord
with the conventional reading of the
United Nations Charter but what's
relevant here is that the conclusions
just about invariably
rely crucially on the ubiquitous phrase
it seems to me and so on and you might
test so just as an illustration tek
witty regards as the hardest question in
his words that is the british bombing of
urban centres in germany up to the end
of the war waltzer concludes that such
bombing quoting him after the immediate
threat posed by hitler's early victories
had passed was entirely indefensible
maybe so but if you check you'll find
there's no argument apart from the
statement that the policy seems cruel
well I think it does seems cruel to me
at least about what does Just War Theory
have to say where does it enter into the
argument and why are relevant facts
disregarded there are after all relevant
facts well the character the theory is
revealed further
and we look at the examples that Walter
is just about a half a dozen examples
which are just listed no argument or
discussion to show the to show that Just
War theory applies leaving in his words
no doubts the examples are mostly
unconscious although one might we'll ask
why some of these examples are chosen
but not others for example the Russian
invasion of Czechoslovakia is given as a
case where there is no doubt but not
given is the Israeli invasion of Lebanon
which I suppose had about a hundred
times as many casualties and many more
during the 22 years of occupation of
Lebanon of southern Lebanon in defiance
of Security Council orders so maybe
there's a reason maybe there isn't but
whatever it is it's not given that's all
examples except one the last example of
a case where Just War theory applies
leaving no doubt is the Egyptian
challenged Israel in 1967 that's the
sole example in the long period covered
we're just were theory allegedly
demonstrates that a preemptive strike it
was just beyond all doubt
well maybe the selection of cases and
the conclusions are correct and maybe
they're not but what's relevant here is
the Just War Theory plays little if any
role in the argument which reduces
pretty much to declarations of personal
preference well I won't go on that these
are to my knowledge fairly
representative selections from the most
highly regarded literature and I think
it's fair to conclude more generally
that we learned very little about Just
War from Just War theory although we do
learn something about the prevailing
intellectual
climate in which the theory is presented
and honored well it's not turn to the
second source of potential insight
second source of potential insight into
just war theory that is their intuitive
moral judgments well here we are turning
to what was traditionally called moral
philosophy I think it's more aptly
described as moral psychology in modern
terms it's after the divorce of science
and philosophy in the mid 19th century a
century before that David Hume had done
his classic work on what he called the
Springs and origins of human nature
human recognized that knowledge and
belief are grounded in what he called a
species of natural instincts part of our
inherent mental nature he recognized
also that something similar must be true
in the domain of moral judgment his
reason was that our moral judgments are
unbounded in scope we are constantly
applying them in systematic ways to new
circumstances in a manner that's
intelligible to others hence they too
must be founded on general principles
that are part of our nature
although beyond what he call their
original instincts meaning the narrower
instincts that we share with animals
well that insight which I think is
accurate should lead directly to efforts
to develop something like a grammar of
moral judgment that's an enterprise very
much like the inquiry into the
principles that are encoded somehow in
our brains that permit us to do what you
and you and I are now doing and more
broadly to produce and understand
linguistic expressions over an unbounded
range and use the
in a way which is appropriate to
circumstances and intelligible to others
even though they may be quite new in our
own history or unexperienced
in fact all of history well as was
recognized a century before Hume these
principles must be universal
hence grounded in their nature and the
basis for acquisition of any particular
language today we would say that the
principles of language and moral
judgment are part of their genetic
endowment part of human biology in both
cases they're culturally specific and
universal aspects in both the case of
internal faculties of language and moral
judgment these things can be studied
they're part of science in fact studied
in rather similar ways inquiry into the
moral faculty in these terms was
undertaken by the leading American moral
and political philosopher of late 20th
century John Rawls who relied explicitly
on the analogy of two linguistic
theories that were being developed in
the 1960s at the time that he was
writing his classic work theory of
justice Rawls in fact put this aspect of
his work aside under severe criticism by
moral philosophers turned to core issues
for him now the criticisms were
reexamined and I think adequately
refuted in a doctoral dissertation a few
years ago by John McHale who is now a
law professor at Georgetown forthcoming
book of his based on the dissertation
develops this and also presents
empirical investigation of moral
judgments in puzzling thought
experiments that have been designed by
moral philosophers this experimental
work reveals that
intuitions in these quite puzzling cases
are typically instantaneous and
reflexive in adults and children with
systemic change
through early childhood development much
as in other aspects of development he
then goes on to develop a theoretical
explanation in terms of fixed principles
that can be regarded as a development of
roles theory of justice and the much
earlier work of Hume and other classical
writers on our natural instincts there's
another book soon to come out by Harvard
primatologist and cognitive scientist
mark Hauser carrying such inquiries
further includes comparative studies and
more general ideas about what he calls
the moral organ analogous to the
language organ other sub components of
the cognitive systems that are a core
part of our biological nature well in
recent years these topics have become a
lively field of theoretical and
empirical inquiry the for many points of
view incidentally this is a study of
principles that underlie intuitive
conceptions of justice and rights and
their cultural variety their limited
cultural variety and their universal
properties that could someday provide
foundations for a more substantive
theory of just war but it remains
largely the task for the future though
it's underway and interesting and
interesting ways well finally a couple
of words on the codification of these
intuitive judgments in the past century
to keep through the period after World
War two although the earlier conventions
have very clear and significant
contemporary relevance a conventions of
1907 for example can come back to that
if you like the post Second World War
codification of the laws of war that
consists primarily of the UN Charter the
Geneva Conventions and the Nuremberg
principles later adopted by the General
Assembly
well as you know I'm sure the Charter
bars the threat or use of force except
in two instances if authorized by the
Security Council of the United Nations
or under Article 51 of the Charter in
self-defense against armed attack until
the Security Council acts the phrase
armed attack is conventionally
interpreted in terms of Daniel Webster's
principle which extends armed attack to
cases where in his words the necessity
for action is urgent his instant
overwhelming and leaving no choice of
means and no moment of deliberation any
other resort the force is a war crime in
fact the supreme international crime
encompassing all the evil that follows
and the words of the Nuremberg Tribunal
I was high level UN panel meeting in
issued its report in December 2004
included among others former National
Security Advisor Brent Scowcroft
it concluded that article 51 needs
neither extension or restriction of its
long understood scope it should be
neither rewritten nor reinterpreted last
September the UN World Summit reaffirmed
quoting that the relevant provisions of
the Charter are sufficient to address
the full range of threats to
international peace and security
these summit and further endorsed the
responsibility to commit ourselves to
helping States build capacity to protect
their populations from genocide war
crimes ethnic cleansing and crimes
against humanity and to assisting those
which are under stress before crises and
conflicts breakout the summit granted no
new right of intervention to individual
states or regional alliances whether
under humanitarian or
professed grounds and it established no
responsibility to protect the contrary
to it was widely alleged in news reports
and commentary the high-level panel of
December 2004 had reached the same
conclusion in words that were
specifically directed at international
and intellectual opinion and state
practice in the West in recent years its
words were these for those impatient
with declaring article 51 to be
appropriate as formulated the answer
must be that in a world full of
perceived potential threats the risk to
the global order and the norm of
non-intervention on which it continues
to be based is simply too great for the
legality of unilateral preventive action
as distinct from collectively endorsed
action to be accepted allowing one to so
act is to allow all allowing one to so
act as to allow all now here the panel
is proposing the principle of
universality namely that we apply to
ourselves the same standards we do to
others if not more stringent ones now
that's perhaps the most elementary of
moral truisms and it's the foundation of
Just War theory if that theory is to be
taken at all seriously the principle
however is flatly rejected in the elite
intellectual moral and political culture
of the most powerful states and six plis
utley rejected by official doctrine that
includes the expositors and advocates of
Just War theory also includes a
substantial legal literature it's pretty
easy to Delta illustrate there's plenty
of material on print about it well in
this and we can draw some conclusions
from that in this connection and by
saying that it's worth remembering some
eloquent words
on the principle of universality
foundation of Just War theory in any
serious moral theory the comments by
Justice Robert Jackson he was the chief
of counsel for the prosecution at
Nuremberg he informed the tribunal that
if certain acts of violation of treaties
or crimes they are crimes whether the
United States does them or whether
Germany does them and we are not
prepared to lay down a rule of criminal
conduct conduct against others which we
would not be willing to have invoked
against us we must never forget that the
record on which we judge these
defendants is the record on which
history will judge us tomorrow
to pass these defendants a poisoned
chalice is to put it to our own lips as
well the supreme international crime for
which the defendants were hanged at
Nuremberg was defined clearly enough by
justice Jackson at Nuremberg he proposed
to the tribunal that an aggressor is a
state that is the first to carry out
invasion of its Armed Forces with or
without a declaration of war of the
territory of another state illustrations
of that too are easy enough to find and
others are on the horizon it's again
noteworthy that these considerations are
virtually excluded from the dominant
intellectual and moral culture in the
West rather generally although we have
no difficulty at all in applying them to
official enemies
well once again there's nothing special
about our own country in this respect
except that it's more powerful than
others
such evasions with regard to the acts of
one's own state are close to universal
they disfigure intellectual history as
far back as you go to the maximum of
Tacitus that i quoted we may add an
observation by President John Adams
power always thinks it has a great soul
and vast views beyond the comprehension
of the week I think that's another
near-universal again all too easy to
illustrate from the traditional practice
of governments and the educated classes
within them well to return to the
beginning what can one learn from Just
War Theory my feeling is that from the
literature on Just War we learn mostly
about the prevailing moral and
intellectual climate in which we live
scientific inquiry into moral psychology
and its roots in our nature may someday
provide important insights but practice
cannot wait for that day any more than
engineering has waited for physics or
medicine for biology for centuries in
these cases which are much simpler ones
and much more accessible to inquiry than
human nature thirdly the codification of
laws of war has over time had a notable
civilizing effect but the gap between
professed ideals and actual practice is
much too large to be tolerated in my
opinion thanks
your chance to talk repeat that
questioners won't be filmed so you can
feel free to talk
sir I was just wondering if you believe
that the United States of America has a
responsibility to intervene in cases
where just war says that it is justified
to intervene do I think that there's a
responsibility to intervene in cases
where Just War Theory concludes that it
is correct to intervene that the
question personally I agree with the UN
Charter the high-level UN panel of
December 2004 and the UN World Summit
which I quoted but I can't really answer
the question because as far as I can
determine you can tell me if I'm wrong
Just War Theory never tells you anything
it doesn't tell you when it's proper to
intervene what it tells you is I think
it's proper to intervene well you know I
I may also think so but there's a big
gap between assertion and argument
between surmise and evidence so if you
can tell me where Just War Theory
entails that we ought to intervene we
can consider the question but until ads
don't done we can't really consider the
question
sir I was wondering I'm sorry my dear
sir I was wondering do you believe that
it would have been right to reassess
article 51 of the UN Charter and you
believe that by not reassessing and not
rewriting it it loses relevancy I'm
sorry I didn't get it by by say it again
by not reassessing it not recess are you
writing it if you believe it loses it's
it it has been reassessed repeatedly for
example by the high-level UN panel of
December to that issue news report on
2004 with many distinguished
participants I mentioned Brent Scowcroft
but there are others yes that's exactly
what they did they reassessed the UN
Charter and their conclusion is what I
read the UN World Summit last September
again reassessed the UN Charter and
that's what it concluded maybe there
should be a further reassessment fine
then let's undertake it and let's
consider their arguments or other
arguments but we can't say that it
hasn't been reassessed and what we can
say that we haven't paid any attention
to it well that's possible in fact true
but it certainly has been reassessed by
very respectable and leading figures and
their conclusions in my opinion at least
are pretty justified however I get back
to the main topic I don't think just
work tell Theory tells us anything about
that when we judge these things we're
judging them on another basis on the
basis of actual evidence about what
happens in particular cases in terms of
our fundamental moral principles which
we should try to explicate and apply
like the principle of universality
that's the way we should reassess it
also we should I think think seriously
about the statement that I quoted of the
December 2004 panel that was directed to
people like us it was directed to
intellectual opinion in the West and can
read it again
what they said is the foundations of
world order based on the principle of
non-intervention and the affairs of
others not forceful intervention is too
important and too fragile to be
destroyed or the consequences will be
terrible because for one to act is to
grant the authority to all at least if
we believe in elementary moral
principles that's a heavy burden to bear
maybe we can come up with a different
conclusion in some cases actually
personally I think we can but it has to
be argued cerca de Greco he said that
it's possible that article 51 needs to
be reassessed but you mentioned earlier
when you were referencing Walters book
that he said that the Israeli preemptive
strike was just or that he said that the
Israeli preemptive strike was justified
he was now stated that his arguments did
not really have justification by his
theory however in the case of the
preemptive strike he does say that there
are several criterion that are necessary
for the Israeli attack to be justified
specifically the fact that these
Egyptian army was standing at a state of
readiness that the Israeli army was
incapable of holding so under article 51
even though Egypt had not yet invaded
Israel that they they were not at war
however what Egypt was doing tactically
put Israel at a severe disadvantage so
under our modern definition of war it
seems to me that that ought to be it
seems to me it seems logical that it
ought to be called an act of war what
Egypt was doing putting Israel at such a
disadvantage so doesn't article 51
definitely need some reason article 51
clearly does not apply all right read
article
we can argue that we can argue that it
was justified but we can't say that
article 51 justifies it not under Daniel
Webster's characterization or any other
one that's accepted by the international
community we might argue and here's
where I think you could make an argument
that if you consider the range of issues
that arose at the time the pre-emptive
strike was justified maybe one can give
such an argument but the point is that
no argument is given to that effect
none of the relevant facts are
considered and this is regarded as one
of the half-dozen cases where Just War
Theory entails that the use of military
force was legitimate just were theory
doesn't entail that women tell anything
it what it tells you is well I Michael
Werth Walter believed this was justified
but without giving any reasons and
without looking into the background
if you look into the background it's a
lot more complex than that it's a lot of
literature and scholarship on it the
u.s. didn't agree there were all sorts
of possibilities you could have taken I
mean I don't want to if you want to run
through the background but it's quite
intricate and complex going back to the
question of free passage through the
Straits of Tiran
and whether that should be brought to
the world Court which the US and Israel
refused to do and he insisted on
involves Israeli strikes against Syrian
targets all sorts of things so yes
there's a complicated background you
could look at them you could decide
maybe that in the light of these complex
these complex circumstances perhaps
Israel is entitled to make a preemptive
strike but that's not what's claimed
what's claimed is that without looking
at any evidence Just War Theory whatever
it is it's not easy to determine Just
War Theory entails that this is one of
the half-dozen cases in the last century
in which the use of force was no doubt
legitimate and the only case in which
preemptive strike was legitimate and we
can also raise the question of
universality I mean I don't believe
and I'm sure you don't believe that Iran
has a right to say carry out terrorist
acts in the United States right now but
undoubtedly it's under serious threat
and undoubtedly the threat is simply
overwhelming as compared with Iran's
capacities but with the outrageous to
suggest that of course and if it's
outrageous to suggest that why is it
legitimate in this case I mean for one
to act is to give the right to all and
we can give a whole lot of other
examples I mean let me give it even more
outrageous one okay not not this except
that of course but just as an example
nobody I know of whose semi sane that
goes out every December 7th and
celebrates Pearl Harbor Day however if
we use these arguments you can do it
Japan on December 7th attacked US
military bases in our in to effectively
to US colonies territories claimed by
the u.s. Hawaii and Philippines
Tech military bases the Japanese were
perfectly capable of being of reading
what was being written in US public
journals and in fact US intelligence
which had cracked the Japanese codes
know that they knew about it and what
was being written going all the way up
to the high military command being
reported by you know political
commentators and the New York Times was
that the United States was that b-17s
were running off the Boeing assembly
line that designs to be able to burn the
to the ground the what they were called
the antiques in which the Japanese lived
these wooden cities burn em to the
ground with their b-17 attacks and
furthermore b-17s were being shipped
from the Atlantic where they were needed
to pacific bases in preparation for such
attacks well you know is that a threat
yeah that's a pretty serious threat does
that justify Pearl Harbor I mean not in
ten million years but if that doesn't
why does Weis
justify
my birthday incidentally so I have a
special interest in that day sir I can't
see I'm sorry I really sir appear
cadet Hobson I just wanted to know if
you thought our operations in a war were
preempted or preventive and sorry I
couldn't hear the first point do you
think our operations in Iraq are
preventive or pre-emptive and do you
think that our operations in Iraq or
just or unjust well the there was
interesting terminology in that the
administration presented it and in fact
the National Security Council described
you know they had that in mind but more
generally as pre-emptive war but it
certainly isn't pre-emptive war by any
stretch of the imagination more
accurately you could call it preventive
war okay you say we have to prevent a
potential attack against us personally I
don't see much justification for that
even if you accept that they believed
all the reports that Colin Powell was
giving at the UN Security Council and so
on even if we accept that all that was
believed it doesn't seem to me that a
preventive war in such a case is
legitimate and as you know the world
didn't think so either
there were international polls taken on
this and outside the United States and
to a limitless to a more limited extent
England you could barely find a country
in the world where support for it was
above ten percent in fact the only two
exceptions in the international polls
that were taken were India and Israel
but both of them had something different
in mind
what they had in mind was their own
repression of occupied territories
Kashmir and the occupied territories
yeah they like the idea of preventive
war
but they weren't talking about this how
are the rest of the world was almost
non-existent you know ten percent or
less was is it and again we have the
same question
if preventive war is legitimate under
those circumstances it's legitimate for
everybody okay that means it's
legitimate for Iran today I mean to take
another case it is simply undeniable I
read it right in the US official
document that the United States has been
carrying out a terrorist war against
Cuba since 1960 I mean at first it was
with direct participation in more recent
years is just with tolerance but that
has happened isn't even questionable no
John F Kennedy assigned his brother
Robert Kennedy the task of running the
terrorist war I was to be his highest
priority Robert Kennedy's official no
more or less official biographer
historian Arthur Schlesinger who was
well-known historian it was a Kennedy
member of the Kennedy a team a Latin
American advisor he writes that Robert
Kennedy's task was to bring the terrors
of the earth to Cuba and if you look
back at the record it was no joke and it
continues now still based on US soil and
the u.s. harbors of happily harbors
terrorists who were involved in it
does that give cube of the right to
carry out terrorist acts in the u.s.
that they prevent this did it ever give
them the right well I don't think so I'm
sure you don't think so but if
preventive war is legitimate why not and
in fact you know and there are many
other cases where it takes a Lebanon in
1982 when Israel was preparing the
attack and in fact trying desperately to
conjure up an excuse for the attack they
were bombing Lebanon hoping for some
retaliation that could be used as a
pretext and that was a serious attack
killed probably maybe 20,000 people
destroyed a large part of southern
Lebanon
much of it did that give Lebanon the or
the Palestinians in Lebanon the right to
carry out the terrorist acts in Israel
prior to it to prevent the war well I
certainly don't think so I'm sure you
don't but if preventive war is
legitimate under such ambiguous cases as
Iraq why isn't that legitimate so no I
don't think it was just I think it was
aggression sir walzer's legal as
paradigm when he describes it he also
describes three revisions one of which
being the human rights provision saying
that it is justified to intervene if
human rights are being violated would
you give any credence to the argument
that your son Saddam Hussein was in fact
a tyrant that did violate human rights
no he said even though even though there
were other reasons given for war such as
WMD and additionally aggressors or walls
are also describes aggressors as also
being just did you go against the war to
get good a war against and when when and
did he ever lose his status as an
aggressor from the first Gulf War thank
you he lost his status as an aggressor
when he was driven out of Kuwait just as
Israel lost its status as an aggressor
went after 22 years it pulled out 11 but
and I can give plenty of other examples
close to home but as for the human
rights violations they were horrendous
and here is one of the cases where it
really is important to look at facts
before you make decisions and we know
the facts are not secret so yes
Saddam Hussein carried out horrendous
human rights violations in fact he's on
trial for him right now
but have a look at the trial Saddam
Hussein is on trial for crimes that he
committed in 1982 when I killed he's
charged with killing probably accurately
killing about 150 you're signing the
death warrant for 150 or so Shiites who
were
than an uprising yeah that's a crime
that 1982 happens to be an important
year in us-iraqi relations this should
be headlines and a free press in my
opinion it was a very important year
1982 was the year in which Ronald Reagan
dropped your act from the list of states
supporting terrorism so the u.s. that
starts providing him with extensive aid
including military aid including means
to develop biological and chemical
weapons and missiles and weapons of men
and nuclear weapons he was dropped from
Donald Rumsfeld the next shortly after
went the firm up the agreement the next
charge against Saddam Hussein the ones
going to come along it's been announced
is a much more serious crime the
atrocities against the Kurds in 1997
1988 they all unfold massacres Halabja
yeah they were terrible molecule hundred
thousand people u.s. didn't object in
fact the Reagan administration blocked
efforts in Congress even to protest
against it furthermore the support for
Saddam increased and continued in fact
Saddam was given an extraordinary
privilege remarkable he was allowed he
got away with attacking a US naval
vessel and killing 37 soldiers of seamen
in 1987
that's pretty astonishing nobody can get
away with that but we were supporting
the Reagan administration was so
strongly in support of Saddam right
through the worst atrocities they even
let him get away with that I mean in
1980 this continued after the end of the
war with Iran after the worst atrocities
in 1989 Iraqi and nuclear engineers were
invited to the United States to take
part in a conference I was in Portland
Oregon
in which they were a trained in how to
develop weapons of mass destruction
missus 1989 that furthermore George Bush
number one told us why it was being done
they said we have to
aid to Saddam because it's of our
responsibility to help us exporters and
because he contributes to stability in
the region
in fact that continued I don't think
they after the invasion of Kuwait after
he was driven out of quake you know Iraq
was practically bombed in the rubble the
US had total control of the area there
was an uprising April March April 1991
Shiite uprising in the South probably
would have overthrown it there were
rebelling Iraqi generals a good chance
you would have been overthrown
well the Bush administration determined
that they would essentially permit
Saddam the crush it they used military
helicopters other armed equipment they
don't have to do that that led to a huge
massacre and it was described you know
you can go back and read the New York
Times right after that they said well
you know it's regrettable but there's a
consensus among the US and its allies
meaning Saudi Arabia and Britain there's
a consensus that I'm virtually quoting
that Saddam Hussein offers more hope for
the stability of the region than those
who are trying to overthrow it that's
1991 you know yeah the human rights
violations were horrendous
does that even do with invasion no
nothing
pastor Chomsky I'm most regretful that I
have to interrupt the flow of your
thought and your and your a very
interesting presentation unfortunately
we are constrained by military time to
end at this time and but I am happy to
say that the that the occasion the
opportunity for those of you who did not
have an opportunity to ask your question
here may come out in the rotunda I
certainly hope it will there is a
reception immediately to follow but
first sir sear on behalf of the class of
2008 I like to present you with this
gift as a small token of appreciation
for speaking with us tonight thank you
sir
I usually leave gifts for my
grandchildren dope and they get a big
kick out of it that all change the rules
this time I don't know if you can see it
but it's a wonderful picture